est-ce que ça se peut de ne jamais faire
caca si vous faites pas caca
si vous faites pas pipi c'est pareil
vous me direz mais il y a des moyens de
remplacer les reins alors que les
intestins non il y a des gens qui ont
des colostomie qui font caca autrement
et puis vous allez me dire oui mais si
on mange rien on fait pas caca oui c'est
vrai mais statistiquement si vous mangez
rien vous survivez trois semaines et
après
sauf si on a des perfusions mais les
perfusions c'est temporaire et à
l'hôpital par exemple dès qu'on peut on
refait fonctionner le tube digestif donc
on refait caca
à part dans des cas très particuliers et
temporaire tout le monde fait caca il y
a bien des maladies comme la maladie de
hirschrung qu'on appelle aussi le méga
colon
congénital le méga colon congénital
c'est une maladie des nerfs des
intestins qui donnent une constipation
chronique et une occlusion mais même
dans ces cas là il y a pas à tortiller à
un moment ou un autre il faut que ça
sorte d'ailleurs en 2017 il y a des
chirurgiens en Chine qui ont dû retirer
13 kg de matière fécales du côlon d'un
patient qui avait cette maladie c'est du
moment vous étiez pas à table j'espère